many films have been made about Elvis
Presley but bazlerman's 2022 biopic is
the first to tackle the king's lonely
final years
baz luhrmann's elaborates often
anachronistic visual Panache always gets
a lot of attention whether he's
depicting 1890s Paris or 1920s New York
Elvis is no exception with its whirling
roulette wheel camera work and Hip-Hop
remixes of Presley songs but the film's
most daring conceit is arguably the way
it tells the story of Elvis from the
vantage point of Colonel Tom Parker
played by Tom Hanks under a mountain of
Prosthetics and a thick Dutch accent
Parker looks back on his life with the
King as he lies dying in a Vegas
hospital bed in 1997 wandering through a
spectral Casino as the memories come
flooding back I am the man who gave the
world Elvis Presley over the years since
Presley's death Parker has widely come
to be seen as a villain manipulating his
one and only client's trust and taking
far more than a share of the profits
lerman's film doesn't disagree with this
version of The Facts but in Parker's
mind he is Elvis's other half the
Carnival Barker to his Sideshow free the
Snowman to his show man Colonel Tom
Parker was a Kearney pure and simple the
film's most pelling tension is between
the blameless almost victimized Way
Parker sees his own relationship with
Elvis compared with what we the audience
see happening on screen this tension is
exposed early in the film with a brief
flash to 1974 when Elvis collapses
backstage before a concert and Parker
makes it perfectly clear that the only
thing that matters is that he gets back
on his feet and performs
as the film enters its final Act we
revisit that moment in 1974 when Presley
collapses with added context at this
point Elvis has been performing at the
International Hotel in Las Vegas for
years due to the fact that Parker signed
him in to essentially a lifetime
contract in exchange for the Forgiveness
of Parker's massive gambling debts if I
was you I would book it for a hundred
years
[Applause]
well no better time than the present
Parker has also been promising Presley
his first Global tour going back to the
1968 Comeback Special only to
continually delay the start of the tour
for one reason or another the truth
finally comes to light just moments
before the king collapses Parker keeps
delaying the tour because he came to the
United States illegally and doesn't have
a passport his name isn't even Tom
Parker nor was he ever a colonel but I
hear rumors
that Colonel is an alien after his
collapse Presley is given a shot of
amphetamines to get him up and going
again for the show he takes the stage
inebriated and incensed by his manager's
betrayal and in spectacular dramatic
fashion fires Parker in the middle of
his performance
you are fired
it's a deeply satisfying moment even if
it is nothing more than a fantasy
according to Elvis biographer Elena Nash
Presley and Parker's professional
falling out occurred after a show not in
the midst of one and for a completely
different reason furthermore Parker's
immigrant status wouldn't come to light
until after Presley's death there's no
evidence that the king ever suspected
that Parker was anyone other than the
West Virginia native he claimed to be
Parker's counter move however is
accurate to real life after being fired
by Presley Parker retires to his office
and drafts an invoice for unpaid
promotional work dating back to 1955
totaling over 8 million dollars
according to Nash this is based on a
real incident though the exact dollar
amount to the invoice is unknown Elvis's
father Vernon breaks the news to his son
that Parker's bill would bankrupt them
we're gonna lose Graceland
Elvis Furious storms out of his sweets
only to find Parker waiting for him
outside the two men argue viciously
Elvis gnashes teeth and threatens to
kill Parker the colonel in turn
belittles Presley's career reminding him
unfairly but honestly that The Comeback
Special audience that loved him so much
was a plant prompted to cheer by a
flashing Applause sign the scene is in
many ways the climax of the film and
Butler and Hanks give it their all Hanks
delivers the film's theme in the scene
declaring we are the same you and I
we are two heart lonely children
Reaching For Eternity his entreat falls
on deaf ears as Elvis walks out of the
Colonel's life forever
the film Fades the black with a title
card one year later Suddenly It's 1975
and Elvis is now a media curiosity a
real-life version of Sideshow act Parker
always considered him to be the colonel
dressed up the hotel like a carnival
there were posters teddy bears and Hound
dogs all over the place he's gained
weight he's separated from his white
Priscilla and rarely sees his daughter
Lisa Marie and when he's not performing
in Las Vegas he's holed up like a
permanent Graceland there is one glimmer
of hope as talks are apparently ongoing
to have him star with Barbara Streisand
and a remake of A Star is Born though we
know it will never come to be on the
tarmac alongside the private jet he
named after his daughter Elvis and
Priscilla have a tender conversation
like most of the dialogue in the film
its primary focus is to establish for us
the state of Elvis's life and career in
this moment and what his dreams and
goals are Elvis still wants to make one
good movie after dozens of cheap
musicals and worries that nothing he's
done will amount to anything when he
dies
and nobody's gonna remember me
I'll never do anything lasting the film
presents this as Elvis's final
conversation with his ex-wife although
in reality he would live for another two
years
from that scene on the tarmac the film
skips ahead two years to the
announcement that Presley has been found
dead in Graceland at the age of 42.
rather than try to recreate the
spectacle of Elvis's funeral procession
or the massive outpouring of public
grief that followed Lerman uses archival
footage of the real thing he also
includes an audio excerpt from President
Jimmy Carter's statement on Presley's
death in which he said his following was
immense and he was a symbol to people
the world over for the vitality
rebelliousness and Good Humor in this
country not too shabby for a kid who
scandalized the nation just two decades
earlier and choosing not to recreate
Elvis's funeral the film also skips over
the fact that Parker reportedly wore
Hawaiian shirts and baseball cap to the
service and while there trying to strike
deals with mourners according to
biographer James Dickerson we'll never
know whether his behavior came out of
callousness sociopathy denial or some
misguided sense of Showmanship just to
keep everyone talking about him as a
nation Mourns the loss of the king the
film flashes back to Presley's final
perform just weeks before his death
Lerman has thus far been reluctant to
make Butler up as the so-called fat
Elvis but here the young actor is decked
out in a wide pair of jowls and double
chin mumbling and stumbling as he sits
down at the piano and belts out an
emotional rendition of the Righteous
Brothers Unchained Melody sweat pouring
down his face the camera stays tight on
Butler in an intimate slightly
uncomfortable way it's different from
the way any of the film's previous
musical numbers have been shot but soon
we understand the reason why as Lerman
cuts from Butler as Elvis to footage of
the king himself singing accompanied by
a short Montage of the real-life Elvis
in many of the situations we've seen
dramatized in the film it's an
emotionally affecting transition as we
see just how accurately Lerman and
Butler have recreated so many moments in
Presley's life it's also a reminder of
just how powerful Elvis's voice and
presence were even in his final days he
gives a showstopper performance at that
piano and the audience hangs on every
note we still do
in the end Elvis can't speak for himself
so Parker does it for him as he did for
most of their life together Parker
Ponders who or what killed Elvis as he
shuffles about his purgatorial casino
floor in a hospital gown dragging an IV
pole it wasn't the pills and drugs
administered by doctors who should have
known better enabled by Parker Vernon
and Presley's whole Entourage the
so-called Memphis Mafia who were all
complicit in working Elvis to death what
can you do for him Dr Nick
and it wasn't Parker's greed and
mismanagement of Elvis's business which
forced him to continue performing at an
unforgiving pace for years Parker is all
too quick to absolve himself of that
responsibility
I made Elvis Presley now of course it's
we who killed Elvis with our Relentless
love for him and his inability to say no
Parker's monologue here is a fascinating
moment in the film Lerman and Hanks keep
Colonel Parker at arm's length unwilling
to tell the audience how we should feel
about him instead they let the dying
Dutch Carney the Snowman SnoWest to the
very end
after the screen Fades to Black we get a
series of postscripts filling Us in on
how The Saga of Elvis and The Colonel
played out in the years after Presley's
death the film takes Liberties in regard
to what Presley and the rest of the
world knew about Parker's background in
real life it would be 1980 before it
would be confirmed that Parker was of
Dutch descent and entered the country
illegally as a 30 year old man
eventually though Parker's Financial
malfeasance would come to light and in
1982 after a series of lawsuits filed by
Elvis Presley Enterprises a judge ruled
that Parker had no legal claim to any
parts of the Presley estate in his final
two decades Parker spent his days in Las
Vegas puttering around one casino floor
or another or in his immense wealth down
the drain he made few public appearances
or statements emerging from the Shadows
only on rare occasions such as the 1993
release of the Elvis postage stamp
Presley meanwhile far from the Forgotten
Lounge singer he feared he'd become
remains an international Superstar
nearly 50 years after his death and one
of the highest earning dead celebrities
of all time his life and work still
Inspire admiration and Mercy
[Music]